this is coach Steven and Steven um we
get to see garnet at em FS few of what
they call it fuge fuse fuse is fucking
awesome
sugan I ya know that was like sooo good
that time if I mean I like I found my
Halloween cut the male version I loved
it that was so cool I love that pearls
first line is something like oh it's a
good idea when you to fuse your kind of
unstable that's exactly what I thought
I'm like yeah let's put these two
together this is a great idea well and
um uh you know there's a scene where
it's like garnet starts to dance and she
started to like this pelvic thrust and
she just covers Stevens eyes and it's a
big ricer thought like yeah that's a
little you know guys gonna Lily knew
each other get a little bout jenny is
gonna be there oh I felt like that was a
music video going on like I want to see
the little info pop up at the lower left
hand yeah scream let me even you're like
anime Johnson I mean she just like opens
her legs she's just like take it top of
it BAM um but uh-huh
yes I said they pretty much fuse and
they stay in this one plan to like uh
just knock down these pillars pearl
takes off come on Angus yeah what are
you doing just fixing the expose my god
why don't you fix it before we actually
feel that Oh cuz the Sun came up I I do
it to get like a white high throw
unprofessional um so unprofessional
now T uh writer Apple cares um but yes
anyway so she takes off and it'll is not
a coward I want to make that clear
before everybody freaks out and starts
typing Oh Jojo pearl did it to protect
students uh
so she heads back I guess just doesn't
like the fact that she herself is not
the daily strong she's pretty you know
BRE thin lanky and stuff like that but
could fucking sword fight she is so
she's a bit of a wave but she's a sword
fighter yeah but she and she confuse
with them to become a pretty giant cool
thing um but then Steven gets the idea
to go work out and do weights and stuff
like that
he gets the idea more to be a motivation
yeah he actually doesn't quite work out
himself he does a bit where he goes into
four-wheel drive yeah but we don't even
know how long that one cuz I think it
gets interrupted
um but yeah then the garnet Garbett fest
whatever it was called sure light yeah
comes in sorry stone you know real book
uh gets bored like talking about stones
and comes and tries to destroy
everything and parole pretty much has to
stop her but or bam I should say but is
a friend she's not strong enough and
everything and then Steve gives the
motivation says you can be strong in the
real way and she gets drunk in real way
and defeats them through physical force
sees which I guess it's the real way
it's like wait a minute I thought this
was would it make more sense if she like
talked her out of it cuz I'm assuming
the real way was like hey it's not just
well Steven was the one doing the talk
know that you know what though she uses
her mind to get out to wasn't just a
strange she uses her own force against
her so no I guess that does make sense
um yeah see it's not always about brawn
though that certainly helped that uh but
it was pretty cool mad bad what everyone
had to use is Maya the power of
motivational speaking the power of
shouting random things through a
bullhorn you know it well yes sister
echo is indeed faster better faster um
but yeah no I I thought was fun FL was a
good way of showing like they say you
know strong in the real way without
quite hammering it into my channel again
she had user wit to get out of that um
but yeah that Fusion was cool I just
like that they had to take out that
communication center at the beginning
because it was gonna mess with TV oh I
just want I know I more like what what
is the story behind these things y'all
going to different universes and getting
these stones and sound just becoming
more of our interest so like what is
going on like what is this story um I
have no idea
you know is it I haven't explained it
yet you know thankfully Stephen is so
likable and the side stories are so
likable because if not this show would
try to be fuckin its eggs I would just
know I
is going on up at this point I would
have been like fuck would you fucking
explain something but no but all the
side adventures are fun so likeable plus
sugilite yes that is the coolest thing
it's like a five by Devil boner it just
looks so cool but those arms I get the
elbow there's another are going okay go
and have you've seen real sugilite it
actually is purple and has five eyes uh
or well it's very gem like it can be
pores so me know it doesn't really have
eyes you guys fighting that um what in
it but it is real it was named after a
Japanese guy named Sookie with that um
with that opening where she's like
covering the eyes like you know don't
look at them dance that way and stuff
like that at first I was kind of
thinking like not first look my thought
like is that like you know for kid show
is that pushing you open that I thought
back that no there's a Simpsons episode
where Mary shows Lisa dancing is money
Animaniacs gave us finger prints yeah no
and I mean no I remember cuz there's the
Simpsons episode where like Lisa's
dancing to like some sort of dance show
or something like that Homer is like oh
that's a cue and she starts doing kind
of the same thing developing thing goes
our wait a minute and when I was a kid I
never really caught on to like any of
that my gosh she's just dancing weird or
goofy or something like that so I think
would be kind of the same thing I think
there is a part like you know kids spit
younger kids do not catch on to that
kind of stuff usually um if you are
you're very educated and be responsible
but uh Wow
you know they play doctor a house or
house doctor use protection
make sure you have some saran wrap Hema
gun um but ya know I thought oh no
I thought this is why God nearly struck
us with a tornado we survived a tornado
last night actually missed us but still
cool real close um but yeah then I think
the the one other thing that does is
that I think it very well shows people I
think everybody has that moment
especially when they see a movie where
like something looks really strong or
something it's like I'm gonna work I'm
gonna dedicate myself to that
gonna do the muscle train now I'm
getting it one trip to Dunkin Donuts
later you're like always long way to get
this is way too good um but uh uh you
had Dunkin Donuts this morning I did no
I I have like a doughnut every morning
Oh
breakfast of champions it is so good um
but well I guess a but he's just
thinking about food oh yeah now I'm in
doughnut man but it was good to be
healthy good to do bi me we both like
the I run you got like the ellipticals
IV we I know that I eat donuts so I
don't know what you're talking no but is
the one thing that I think like you know
they kind of make a joke about it and so
I know you got to be strong in the real
way it's like strength is one thing
healthy really is like another it's like
it's I just know so many people it's
like god I feel awful I'm just gonna sit
in this room and stare at a screen
instead it's like no go what run do some
move your body around that that's how
you get to happier and healthier go
outside experience sunshine but apply
sunscreen yes
um but yeah it is one of those things
where it's like yes you shouldn't be
doing to be strong be you should be
doing to be happy and healthy um or walk
at night
I prefer night you know that does a
globe but burns me I don't like it son I
don't for you know you need Sun sunburn
don't you sound like John Hurt um I hate
the day though but tries to fill me with
a happiness and it makes me sad dead
um but ya know I weigh it up are you
telling people to get Sun look at you oh
no no no my pace on white is evident you
see all those freckles though that is
from Sun okay that is pure I can't you
know my skin reacts immediately on that
I still go up that is from the sun's
said a temper give you counter this is
sound good oh you're coming out here and
last hour here so I'm gonna do magic
marker gobos you're the way there's now
we're practically glowing if we look
radioactive um but uh good episode
Wonder Bread ain't got nothing on us yes
ah so that's about it we will see you at
the next one later let's go get some
Wonder Bread what's up Doug a doughnut
Wonderbread don't condone it no yeah
you're right
although no
now